We're still in Genesis. Go to chapter
31. [music]
>> And the angel of God spake unto me, I am
the God of Bethl where thou anointed the
pillar and where thou vowest a vow unto
me.
>> So who did the angels say he was?
[music]
>> He says, I am the God of Bethl. Yeah, we
don't have a problem with that. We know
that in the Old Testament, angels
identify themselves as God.
>> Angels don't identify themselves as God.
There's one particular angel, one
particular messenger that identifies
himself as being God, specifically being
Yahweh. You're okay with that? That
angels can identify themselves as Allah?
>> Yeah, why not? If God is obviously
angels don't have
>> Is that what Muhammad agrees with that
angels can claim to be God?
>> No, because no angel is claiming to be
literally God.
>> The angel is claiming to be literally
God. The one who was standing at the top
of the stairway that Jacob saw and made
a bow to him. Does Muhammad agree that
there is a second person within the
Godhead who is known as the angel of God
or the angel of the Lord?
>> No, of course not. And there's no any
there's no Jew that would have agreed
that the angel was literally God.
>> We have a Jew right here who's agreeing.
We got Moses who's writing it and saying
that the angel of God is claiming to be
God who Jacob made a vow to. And Jacob
identifies the angel of God as God. So
unfortunately for you, we got two very
prominent Jews who are claiming that the
angel of the Lord is God himself. So
>> what's up buddy?
>> What's up Adam?
>> You all right
>> man? I'm blessed man and highly favored.
>> Alhamdulillah. But uh I think a better
question is is any is there a prophet
that prayed to a father, son, and holy
spirit and believe that it's necessary
for salvation?
>> We could do that next. First you got to
prove that any of the prophets were Musl
were Muslim.
>> Okay. So there's a difference between
when you think I have a feeling you
think Muslim you think post prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
where
>> nope I believe in just believing in what
constitutes to be a Muslim whether it's
before
>> that's what you got to tell me and then
we'll go from there
>> okay so you don't know what the articles
of faith are
>> what are they
>> so pretty much believing in God alone
believing in his uh revelations
believing in the prophets It's believing
in angels and if you were to accept all
these uh fundamentals then you would be
considered a Muslim.
>> Okay. So believing in the angels like
believing that they just exist or do you
have to believe a certain thing about
them?
>> Like what I mean yeah obviously that
they exist
>> and that's all.
>> I mean what else would there be?
>> So if I if I believe that there are
angels but I don't believe that they
ever communicated with mankind or any
prophets. Am I still a Muslim?
>> You would need to bring proof to support
that claim.
>> I know. I'm not I'm not bringing that as
an argument. I'm saying if that's my
belief, am I a Muslim?
>> I mean, no. Because God never said that
that was something that's impossible.
Unless he said it before.
>> Yeah. But where does it say that in that
article of faith? Cuz you said just
believing in angels. That's pretty
vague.
>> Especially in the Torah. Didn't Isaiah
see a angel?
>> Well, we're not talking about the Torah.
We're talking about your articles of
faith. I'm trying to see if we can
narrow it down. You see how like
>> this is how this is how we come to the
conclusion that the previous prophets
would have been considered Muslims. So
when you say that if a angel interacted
with a human being that wouldn't
necessarily be true when in the Torah
it's literally happened.
>> So when you say to be a Muslim I have to
go with the articles of faith. One of
those being that I have to believe in
the angels. Do I have to believe in
something specific about the angels or
can I just generally believe angels
exist and leave it at that?
>> You have to believe in that that that
they exist. Anything additional would be
required from God himself saying
>> okay. So does God say does Allah say
that I have to believe that angels inter
enter inter uh interacted with mankind
in order to be a Muslim to fulfill that
article of faith? If he gives you a
situation, a circumstance in any of the
scriptures, then yeah, if you were to go
anything that Allah says, you are not
considered a believer.
>> Got it. So, whatever Allah says about
these certain subjects is what I have to
believe in order to be a Muslim. Is that
right?
>> Of course.
>> All right. When you said the first
article was belief in in God, which God
are you talking about?
>> The one true God. The God of Abraham,
Isaac, Jacob, and all the prophets. the
one true God.
>> Yeah.
>> What are some like core descriptions of
him that you know that we can identify
him as the true God?
>> What do you mean like attributes?
>> Yeah. Attributes, qualities,
characteristics that sets him apart and
makes him uniquely the one true God. So
that you know we can be specific.
>> So again, the one true God that Abraham
made a covenant with, that's who we
identify as our God. The God that
Abraham
uh worshiped and prayed to. That's who
we acknowledge as
>> Who? Who is that?
>> That's Allah.
>> Yeah, but what I know that that's
>> what you huffing and puffing for. You
asked the question. I answer your
question.
>> Let me let me help you out. Um, is Allah
who you say is the God of Abraham? Is he
a trinity?
>> Of course not.
>> Does he have hands?
>> No,
>> he doesn't have hands.
>> Not in a sense that we do as humans.
>> I didn't ask that. I just asked if he
has hands or not.
>> No. So when the Quran says that Adam
made Adam was made by the hands of
Allah, you're saying that Allah was
wrong. The Quran's lying.
>> I believe Allah speaks to his creation
in a way that we can comprehend.
>> So when it says that he has hands, is he
lying or
>> No. Again, I believe he's using
personification to allow us to
comprehend what he's telling us.
>> Okay.
>> Doesn't necessarily mean that he
physically used his hands. No, cuz he
also tells us couldn't be and it is his
his will requires no action on his end.
>> Does he have a shin?
>> No, he doesn't have any human
characteristics.
>> So when the Quran says that he was going
to reveal his shin in chapter 68, he's
lying.
>> Personification.
>> Personification of what?
>> It's to get us to understand something.
>> Yeah. What I got you. What do you
understand from that? When it says that
Allah on that day is going to reveal his
shin and people are going to try to
prostrate but won't be able to. What
what do you understand from that? When
it says he's going to reveal his shin,
>> he means reveal his might and people
will then try to repair but it
>> might. Yeah.
>> Where do you get that from? That his
shin represents his might. Can you show
me a verse in the Quran that says that
or a hadith?
>> That's the only cont based off of the
context. That's the only way we can
>> that doesn't that's that's not the only
way. Uh there's another way that you can
understand that to be Allah lifting up
his garment and showing his leg or you
know whatever I don't mean garment but
whatever it is
>> when he says lift up his garment it's
referring to the veil just like in the
story of MS when Moses asked
>> I'm not talking I'm not talking about
that brother please you don't have to go
off
>> you don't have to go off on the veil
focus I'm talking about the shin
>> when he reveals his shin he uncovers
he's going to uncover his shin And
people are going to try to prostrate.
Matter of fact, even the hadith says
that when he does this, then the people
are going to recognize Allah. They're
going to be like, "Oh, that's Allah."
When he shows him their when he shows
them his shin. So what does the shin
symbolize? Since you're saying it's not
an actual shin, what does it mean?
>> It can be interpreted as whatever,
however God manif. We don't know how God
is going to look. So whenever he reveals
himself to us, that's when people are
going to try to then repent.
>> So when he reveals himself as having a
sin, then
>> Well, again, it's not literal. Stop
trying to make it literal.
>> See, but you're not giving me anything.
You're saying it's not what it says, but
you're not giving me something else with
substance. That's that's that's what's
hard for me to
>> Are you saying that there's are you
saying everything in the Old Testament
is literal?
>> This has nothing to do with the Old
Testament. Let me let me let me let me
help you out. God in the scripture in
the actual scriptures says that he is
spirit. So we know that God does not
have a physical caporeal body. But Allah
does not tell you what he is. Does Allah
say he's spirit?
>> He also says he's a man of war.
>> Does Allah say he's spirit?
>> God is light.
>> He's light.
>> Allah is light.
>> Yeah. That's what M said that's why when
he
>> that's what that's what says
>> he he he withdrew a a fraction of his
veil and it collapsed the mountain and
it made Moses fall in conscious
>> so he so he withdrew a fraction of
himself
>> he's n that's what he describes himself
as
>> so he when you say that he withdrew a
fraction of his veil are you saying that
he withdrew a fraction of himself
>> come on man why you being problematic
for no reason
>> why am I being problematic
>> he needs avail himself because his glory
is too strong for the universe to
withstand.
>> That's what I asked.
>> So that's why when Moses said, "Can I
>> That's what I asked."
>> You're That's pretty much what you're
saying.
>> Okay, let's do this.
>> You're saying you're saying by him
removing a portion of his veil that did
he remove part of himself.
>> I didn't say anything about a portion of
his veil. You did. You said when he
removes a fraction of the veil. That's
what you said. I I'm repeating what you
said, not me. I didn't say this. You
said it.
>> You asked me did he remove part of
himself
>> after you said that when he removes of
cuz Allah is light. And you said just
like when he showed himself to the
mountain, he removed a fraction of his
veil.
>> Right?
>> So when he removed a fraction of the a
piece of his veil, he was showing
himself to the mountain.
>> He was allowing the mountain to get a
glimpse of his glory. And just off of a
glimpse, it collapsed.
>> Got you. And that was himself, right?
>> Okay. So, he showed the mountain
himself, a glimpse of himself, and a
tiny glimpse of himself caused the
mountain to crumble. Now, with this
being said, we're still at the question.
Allah's shin, Allah's hands,
specifically the shin, cuz I just want
to know what this means. When it says
that he will reveal his shin, what is he
revealing?
>> I told you. Okay, let's pull up the
verse. Let's see what the taps has to If
you genuinely want to understand and
you're not just being problematic. We
can we can find a better explanation
together if you really want to
understand. But we both know you don't
and you know what it means. You're just
trying
>> Oh, I know what it means.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> Oh, what does it mean then?
>> I told you. I literally gave you an
explanation and you
>> for some reason you didn't like it.
>> You know what it means. Oh, I do. What
does it mean? I told you. I told you,
man. Because I said when God presents
himself to mankind based off of the
context, they will then try to repent
when God shows his glory.
>> It doesn't say he shows his glory. It
says he shows his shin,
>> right? So that's the word that he used
to give that example, however you want
to take it. And you can't translate
every single word perfectly.
>> Now, now guys, it's the mystical magical
Arabic. Now there Hey, we need a we need
a we need a bingo card, Adam, for real.
>> When you guys come up and talk, we need
a bingo card to check off when you guys
hit certain phrases. Cuz I was waiting
on this part. I was waiting on you to
say and and and and see the in the
Arabic, see, we can't
>> we can't translate everything perfectly.
You see,
>> because in English, you take shin as a
very specific thing. But
>> in Arabic, too, the the word is shin.
It's a shin. There's a lot of words in
Arab that can be interpreted or mean
multiple things.
>> Okay. So, what's another word for shin?
6842, I believe.
>> Can you pull it up since you're on your
computer?
>> All right. It says, "The day the shin
will be uncovered, and they are invited
to prostration, but the disbelievers
will not be able." So, the believers
will be able to prostrate after they see
Allah shin, but the disbelievers won't.
What is Allah showing? What is he
uncovering? Is he uncovering what the
verse says he's uncovering? His shin,
his leg bone, or
>> does the verse not mean what it says?
>> I thought you were going to pull the
verse. What's the verse again? 60 what?
>> 6842.
>> All right.
>> All right. What you got, Adam?
>> Okay. So, the word s means pretty much
that it's it can be expressed as a
terrifying re. So when he reveals
himself to the people, it can be
translated to something terrifying for
them to behold.
>> Yeah. What is he beholding? What are
they beholding?
>> However, he manifests himself.
>> And what does the Quran say? Describes
himself. What does the Quran say he's
manifesting?
>> What does the Quran say he's
manifesting? Like I said, it's
interpreted as something terrifying.
>> I'm I'm going to say it. I'm going ask
it again. according to the verse. What
is he revealing? What does it say he's
revealing and manifesting?
>> Bro, you just wanted to be stuck on this
one part. You don't want the
conversation to
>> Hey, if you want if you if you if you
want to drop this, we could progress. I
You want to drop it?
>> Because, you know, it's not hard to
imagine. And I can pull up verses from
the Torah that give similar situations.
>> Do you do you want Do you want to drop
it? If you want to drop it, I'll drop
it. You want to drop it? I mean, it's
kind of off the topic. So, yeah, you're
the one that's stuck on it. We could go
back to the topic.
>> I'll drop it. I'll drop it, guys. I'll
drop it. And I'll I'll tell you why I'm
dropping it. Hold on. I'll tell you why
I'm dropping it. Cuz one, I understand
that none of you can explain tahed. I
understand that ted is so difficult to
understand. It's so difficult to
comprehend. And none of you guys can
explain it or break it down. and that it
sends you into this frenzy of
interpretations and this and that and it
doesn't mean this but it means this. It
could possibly and it it it means
everything else other than what it says.
So I'm I'm willing to allow you to move
past this because I know that is
unexplainable. So you know I'm I'll give
you a pass here. No worries. Now when it
comes to the God cuz this is how we got
here. You're saying that the article of
faith number one being believe in the
God, one God specifically. You're saying
this is the same God of Abraham and I'm
asking you who he is. You couldn't tell
me who he is specifically. So I begin to
ask you for details about him. And this
is how we got into this conundrum. Okay.
>> I said the God that Abraham worshiped.
>> Is he a trinity?
>> No, of course not. None of the prophets
said that their god was a trinity.
>> How do you know what uh any of the
prophets say? their whatever books or
messages that they were given
>> like give me a couple examples.
>> The ten commandments.
>> So that's not a book that's in a book.
What book what book is?
>> Revelation. Okay. The Torah.
>> Okay. The Torah. Got it. Okay. So we can
find out what the prophets taught. What
what prophet specifically in the Torah?
>> Moses. Okay.
>> He's probably the best example to use.
>> All right. Perfect. So we can read the
Torah and we can find out who God is,
what Moses really believed and how he
practiced his religion. And that same
preached about in the Torah is going to
be the same God that is described in the
Quran. Is that right?
>> Mhm.
>> Awesome. Okay. You got your Torah on
you?
>> Yeah.
>> Awesome. Can you go to go to go to the
first book of the Torah for me? Go to
Genesis chapter 28 10-17.
Go ahead if you could read for us
please.
>> 28:10.
>> Yep.
>> Now Jacob went out from Beersa and went
toward Haran. So he came to a certain
place and stayed there all night because
the sun had set. And he took one of the
stones of that place and put on his
head. Then he lay down in that place to
sleep. Then he dreamt and behold a
ladder was set up on the earth and its
top reached for heaven. And there the
angel of God were ascending and
descending on it. And behold, the Lord
stood above it and said, "I am the Lord,
God of Abraham, your father and the God
of Isaac. The land on which you lie, I
will give to you and your descendants
also. Your descendants shall be as the
dust of the earth you shall spread
abroad, to the west and the east, to the
north and the south. And in you, and in
your seed all the families of the earth
shall be blessed. Uh, behold, I am with
you, and I will keep you wherever you
go, and I will bring you back to this
land. For I will not leave you until I
have done what I have spoken to you.
Then Jacob awoke from his sleep and
said, "Surely the Lord is in this place
and I do not did not know it." And he
was afraid and said, "How awesome is
this place? This is none other than the
house of God, and this is the gate of
heaven." Okay.
>> So, Jacob saw God at this place called
Bethl that he named Bethl, right?
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Do you believe that? Is that what
Muhammad teaches? No, he didn't
literally see God because he was talking
about angels ascending and descending.
>> And who and and where was God according
to the verse?
>> Who stood above it and said, "I am the
Lord." Okay, it says that he stood above
it and said, "I am the Lord, your God."
>> Right? So, he saw so he saw a stairway
and he saw angels going up and down the
stairway and at the top of the stairway
he saw God. Right?
>> I can grant that. And it's a dream, too.
So he could have said he saw God in a
dream. That's fine.
>> Okay. So he saw God in a dream. Okay.
Now,
>> and this at this place, this is
specifically called Bethl. This is
important. We're still in Genesis. Go to
chapter 31. You're going to read verse
um 11 to13.
>> And the angel of God spake unto me in a
dream, saying, Jacob, and I said, here
am I. And he said, "Lift up now thine
eyes, and see all the rams which leap
upon the cattle are ring straight,
speckled, and grizzled. For I have seen
all that Laban doeth unto thee. I am the
God of Bethl, where thou anointed the
pillar, and where thou vowest a vow unto
me." Now arise, get out, get thee out
from this land, and return unto the land
of thy kindred.
So, who did the angel say he was?
>> He says, "I am the God of Bethl." Yeah,
we don't have a problem with that. We
know that in the Old Testament, angels
identify themselves as God. That doesn't
mean
>> angels don't angels don't identify
themselves as God, but there's one
particular angel, one particular
messenger that identifies himself as
being God, specifically being Yahweh.
And so, you're okay with that? That
angels can identify themselves as Allah?
>> Yeah, because God is obviously using
them. Yeah, if God is obviously angels
don't have so
>> they're only speaking out of what God
permitted them to speak. So nobody's
going to assume that because an angel is
saying he's God that they're literally
God. They're a representative of God.
>> Angels can
>> That's a low tier argument.
>> Identify as Allah. Man, we are we sure
are racking up these uh these quotes at
the end of the year, guys. an hour 35
minute mark to an hour and 36.
>> Okay. So, just to be clear and because I
want to I want us to be clear. You said
that yes, angels can identify themselves
as being Allah. Is that right?
>> I said I don't have an issue with it if
if God is allowing the angel to
>> So that's a yes, right?
>> God as a representative.
>> So that's so that's a yes, right?
>> I don't see a problem with that. Yeah.
>> Can you show me that in the Quran?
>> In the Quran, what of an angel saying
that they're God? that anybody else
other than Allah can be identified as
God?
>> No. Because the angel is not claiming to
be God. They're saying that they're God
in a sense that whatever their message
is going to be that it is.
>> So they're claim So they're claiming to
be God in a sense.
>> No.
>> Oh, you just said You just said
>> representatives of God.
>> You just said they are. So I'll ask it
again. Who did the angel claim to be?
>> The angel is claiming to be God in a
sense that he's the representative of
God.
>> So the angel claims to be God, right?
>> Okay. Is that what Muhammad agrees with
that angels can claim to be God?
>> No. Because no angel is claiming to be
literally God.
>> Did this angel claim to be God?
Literally,
>> did the angel say that he's the one true
God that created the heavens and the
earth? Or is he just identifying
himself?
>> For example, um when you read the first
passage in in in the dream, after he
after Jacob made a dream, he made an
oath. Who did he make an oath to?
>> God. Very good. And he made an oath to
God at Bethl.
>> Okay.
>> Who did the angel say that Jacob made an
oath to in chapter 31 that we read
>> to Jacob?
>> No. No. Who did Jacob say? I mean, who
did the angel say that Jacob made an
oath to at Bethl?
>> To God. Didn't
>> If you need to go back to it, go back to
it. Remember verses. Go to verse 13.
>> Just tell me. What was it? God.
>> Verse. I need you to read. I can't. Me
telling you is not going to happen.
>> I am the God of Bethl where thou
anointed the pillar and where thou
vowest unto me. So yeah, now rise get
unto thee.
>> So who's the one saying that I am God? I
am the God of Bethl. Who's saying that?
>> God.
>> Read verse 11.
>> The angel. Okay. The angel.
>> Thank you. So the angel is claiming to
be God and claiming to be the one who
Jacob made a vow to on that day, right?
>> Okay.
>> So there's no confusion. The angel is
claiming to be literally God, the one
who was standing at the top of the
stairway that Jacob saw and made a vow
to and made a vow to him. So, does
Muhammad agree that there is a second
person within the Godhead who is known
as the angel of God or the angel of the
Lord?
>> No, of course not. And there's no any
there's no Jew that would have agreed
that the angel was literally God. It was
the manifest.
>> We have a Jew right here.
>> We have a Jew right here who's agreeing.
We got Moses who's writing it and saying
that the angel of God is claiming to be
God who Jacob made a bow to. And Jacob
identifies the angel of God as God. So
unfortunately for you, we got two very
prominent Jews who are claiming that um
that the angel of the Lord is God
himself. So with that being said,
>> the angel of Okay, listen to what you
just said. The angel of the Lord
>> is somehow the Lord. Hey, take that up
with Moses.
>> Come on, man. You told me.
>> Come on, man.
>> You told me
>> that we can understand what Moses
believed
>> from the Torah.
>> So, I took you to the Torah, the very
first book of the Torah. And I'm showing
you, and we're reading together what
Moses believed. And according to Moses's
belief, he believed that there was
Yahweh and then there was the angel of
Yahweh who shares the same nature as the
one who sends him. That ain't
>> so when So when he said
>> So when he said our God is one, was he
talking about the angel of Absolutely?
Absolutely. Of the Lord.
>> He's talking about the angel of the
Lord. He's talking about the father who
sends the angel. And he's talking about
the spirit of the Lord, the spirit of
Yahweh. All three persons Moses
identifies as God in the Torah. All
>> okay. Do you have any evidence of
anybody ever prophet
>> saying that the angel of the Lord was
God?
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa. Is this This is Moses,
right? Moses is writing this. Correct.
>> Okay.
>> And Moses here writes that the angel of
God claims to be God. Right.
>> Right. But the point is nobody ever
interpreted that as God.
>> Everybody interprets that as God
himself. This is for example
>> Christianity did but not any Jewish.
>> So So was it the angel that was at the
top of the staircase that that Jacob
saw?
>> Okay. You need to understand how God
spoke to the children of Israel.
>> I don't need historical language that he
uses. So when he says
>> who was there at the top of the
staircase?
>> Who was at the top of the staircase?
>> Who was that?
>> And then he also says it was the angel
of the Lord. The angel of the Lord is
the representative of God.
>> So who was there at the top of the
staircase?
>> It's identified as God.
>> Who is the one that Jacob made the vow
to?
>> To God. Of course. God knows which.
>> Who does the angel according to Moses
say he is who the vow was made to?
>> To God of course. And so the angels says
that that was me that was at the top of
the staircase that you made a vow to,
right?
>> Okay.
>> So the angel is claiming to be Yahweh.
Moses is writing about the angel being
Yahweh. There's your prophet who claimed
that. So on top of this, this is where
all of this leads. We see that Moses
believed that God was multi-personal,
which directly goes against what the
Quran teaches. And so therefore,
therefore, Moses wasn't a Muslim.
>> You're making a huge stretch right now.
So listen to what you just said. The
angel of the Lord is somehow the one
true God that created the heavens and
the earth and angels somehow. And this
was never a belief prior to
Christianity.
>> Then why is Moses believing that?
>> That is a belie
brother. Stop making these basic
baseless claims. and deal with the
argument. Stop lying. You don't got to
lie here. You can be honest. If you
don't know about something, Adam, relax.
If you don't know about something, I
would suggest you just don't don't try
to act like you're you know something
and you and you're trying to argue it
cuz that that looks foolish.
>> It's clear who knows because any rabbi
that you say this to would laugh at you.
>> I don't give a crap what any rabbi would
say today.
>> I could I could call I could call a
rabbi up right now and he would agree
with me.
>> Well, no you won't. Really?
>> Let's be real. He's not a real rabbi
then. He's probably some
>> Oh, now he's not a real rabbi. Now he's
not a real rabbi, guys. Because
>> no rabbi agrees with a literal angel
that somehow himself.
>> Let's see. Let's see, man. Habibi.
>> The Jews were very monotheistic. Strict
monotheism.
>> Yeah, this is strict monotheism. And and
it shows that Muhammad was a pagan.
Muhammad was a pagan. Let me call my
rabbi. Hold on.
>> If if somebody is associating Adam, hold
on. I'm trying to call my rabbi. Hold
on. Hopefully he answers.
>> If you don't speak Hebrew, then don't
even waste your time.
>> I I agree with you. If you don't speak
Hebrew, then it'll make no sense. Let's
see if my rabbi answers, man. He might
be busy doing rabbi stuff.
>> Okay. I'm willing I'm willing to grant
you.
>> This man will never be answering me when
I'll be calling.
>> I'm willing I'm willing to grant you
your claim. But do you have any evidence
that anybody understood this to be
literally God himself?
>> How many times do you want me to show
you?
>> Do you have any prophet or any scripture
that says the Lord? How many times do
you want me to
>> How many times do you want me to show
you what Moses is saying? How many
times?
>> Right. But Moses also says God is one.
>> Absolutely. So demonstrating that the
one God exists as three persons. So
instead instead of getting out of here
instead of getting out of here with the
Muslim dogma and you're trying to read
the Muslim dogma into the text, it
doesn't work. Habib,
>> so I
let me ask again, let me ask again.
Would you would you agree that if you
pray to something that you're worshiping
it? That that's worship?
>> Praying to it? Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, watch this. Go to We're
still in Genesis. You ready?
>> But I got a quick question. So, I did
endorship.
>> Before any quick question, focus. Focus,
please.
>> We've been focused.
>> Okay, good. So, I want to stay in
Genesis. Go to chapter 48. Now, I'm
about to show you something. About to
show you something real good. Hi.
>> 48. What?
>> One second. Let me get there. Watch
this. Watch this. Lucky. Uh uh. Watch
this. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Oh, I
didn't put the mark. My bad. Watch this.
I think it's uh like 16 or something
like that.
>> So, what you're saying is God waited
4,000 years to announce he's a trin.
>> All right. Here we go. Go to go to
chapter 48. Read verse 15 and 16. And by
the way, this is Jacob as he's blessing
the sons of Joseph. So, he's praying to
God and he's blessing the sons of
Joseph. Go ahead and read verse 15 and
16. 28:15
>> 48 Genesis chapter 48. Watch this. Did
anybody interpret the angel of the Lord
to be to be God? Literally, I just
showed you just now. I'm going to show
you another one. And remember,
>> he blessed Joseph and said, "God before
whom my fathers Abraham and Isaac did
walk, the God which fed me all my life,
long unto this day, the angel which
redeemed me from all evil, blessed the
lads, and let My name be named on them
and the name of my fathers Abraham and
Isaac and let them grow into a multitude
in the midst of the earth.
>> Who is who is Jacob praying to?
>> God.
>> And
>> what do you mean? And
>> read read it again. Verse 16.
>> This is a quote
>> from Jacob who's blessing the sons.
>> The angel which redeemed me from all
evil.
>> So he's
>> finish it.
>> Okay. Bless the lads and bless the boys.
>> Who is he asking? Who is he praying to?
to bless the boys.
>> The angel which redeemed me from all
evil. Bless the lads and let my name be
named upon. Okay.
>> What's the answer?
>> He's praying to God
>> and
>> he's bro. Okay. So when he says the
angel, the angel is what he knows as the
representative of God that protect.
>> Who is he praying to?
>> When he says to God
>> and
>> he's not praying to the angel, bro.
>> All right. I'm gonna ask you one last
question and then uh depending on your
answer depends on if we continue or not.
Who does Jacob ask to bless the boys?
Who does he ask? Who does he who does he
address and ask to bless the boys?
>> So when he starts when you start chap
verse 15, he said God before whom my
fathers Abraham and Isaac did walk. So
obviously he's saying all this to God.
>> And
>> so the answer is God obviously. And
>> and what?
>> Yeah.
>> Are you trying to say the angel is the
rep?
>> Get off the stage. You absolute dimwit
of a liar. This is what you guys have to
do. This is what the Muslims have to do.
Y'all see that? Y'all see what the
Muslims have to do? You cannot stand to
be honest because once you're honest,
Islam is done. An honest Muslim is a
what, ladies and gentlemen? What is an
honest Muslim? Alitam is. Hold on. Let
me put the chat on the on the screen so
you guys can see it. chat. What's an
honest Muslim? Exactly. Exactly. An
honest Muslim is a what is an ex-Muslim.
The only way that you remain a Muslim is
if you are dishonest with yourself,
dishonest with the texts presented to
you, dishonest with your reasoning,
dishonest with your common sense,
dishonest intellectually, dishonest
spiritually. The only way you stay a
Muslim is by being dishonest. You heard
it here first, folks. Well, actually,
you didn't hear that here first. You
know, you heard it here. You saw it. You
saw it. The verse says, "Jacob blessed
Joseph and said, "The God before whom my
fathers Abraham and Isaac walked, the
God who has been my shepherd all my life
long to this day, the angel who has
redeemed me from all evil, bless the
boys." Who is he saying the angel is?
Who's the angel according to Jacob?
According to Jacob, the who before his
fathers Abraham and Isaac walked the God
who has been the shepherd, his shepherd
all his life TO THIS DAY. TO THIS DAY,
Y'ALL SEE THIS. TO THIS DAY, I got the
verse on the screen, y'all. The angel
who redeemed me from all evil bless the
boys and in them let my name be carried
on. LOOK WHO HE'S ASKING. LOOK AT WHAT
HE'S asking the angel, the messenger of
Yahweh. How in the world can the angel
bless the young boys? Blessing comes
from God alone. How in the world can can
the angel have a say so in Jacob's name
being carried on and the names of the of
Abraham and Isaac being carried on
through these boys? How in the world can
the angel have any say in whether they
grow into a multitude? That would mean
that he's a creator. Let them grow into
a multitude in the midst of the earth.
Means that you are creating generations.
You're creating offspring. The angel is
the creator, the redeemer, the God of
Abraham and Isaac. This is who Jacob
believes the angel is. You wanted me to
You wanted me to show you any Jew, any
prophet who believed the angel was
literally God? I just showed you. You
got Jacob, you got Moses, and then you
got the rest when we go throughout the
Tanakh in the Old Testament. I can show
you plenty of verses. Man, that's good
Bible. That's good Bible, is it not? Is
that good Bible chat? Is that good Bible
chat? So, not only do we have Jacob, not
only do we have Moses, but we have the
angel himself saying, "Yo, I'm the God
that you met at Bethl, the one whom you
made a vow to. That was me. That was me.
Now do what I say." That's what the
angel of the Lord says. The angel of
Yahweh worshiped, prayed to, adored,
acknowledged. Stop playing with me, man.
Stop playing on the Bible. That's good
Bible. Don't play in the Bible.